not going to dress out yet so you can
see my legs
uh on the chico okay
so in Chico
um
you're you don't want to roll your
patella
you don't want to roll it
do you see that you don't you don't want
your patella to go like that
and so most of the
the distance that you think you need to
move
is not achieved on straight lines okay
so first point don't roll your patella
second point the distance that you think
you need to move
is not done on straight lines
if you CR if you generate the distance
in straight lines you're going to roll
your patella this is no way okay
um so you can you can rotate on your
patella
you can't linearly go
across the mat you cannot Traverse the
map now your Aikido geometry never if
your part of your kihonawaza is you're
presented with an x y axis and your task
as Naga is to start it rotating so you
should never Traverse across the mat
linearly okay so if we're doing uh let
me do it on this side
and we're doing it even now yet I should
not go like that
so right here on that back leg
you rotated your patella you see that
and now it's scraping
and I would in shorts I'd be getting a
rope burn or a map burn okay but you
rolled your patellas
so what you can do instead is you bring
him over there and you can rotate on
that patella
rotate on that patella put the other
patella down and you can rotate on that
other one
so okay and now when you do the second
kazushi you're picking up rotating on
this patella put the leg there and then
the throw clips
[Music]
now do it again
why I only get to rotate on my left
patella in
right patella
left patella rotate
throat
[Music]
I'll rotate on the right patella
on the Left To Tell us
on the right Coachella right
I'll do it wrong
I move across roll my patella
roll my patella
that you can you can only do this
disliking the eye down all right let's
try it